so I'm Cameron Davidson Pilon thanks for
being here I really appreciate it thanks
for pie data for hosting this and
inviting me the title of this talk is
mistakes I've made so I mean I could
ramble on a long long time for how many
mistakes I've made
but I've narrowed it down to like five
or six sort of examples where I thought
I was doing the right thing
something went wrong and I'll explain
why it what went wrong and how I fix
that if I did fix it so it'll still be
very humbling talk in retrospect it's a
lot of my mistakes are very embarrassing
you might catch on immediately as to
like what the mistake is if you do
awesome just don't shout it out
so there'll be lots of lots of this on
my face like lots of like Oh course like
why didn't I do that earlier but so Who
am I a little bit more about me I'm the
author of Bay Z methods for hackers it's
the online ebook to learn Bayesian
methods with more like practical sense
in mind it's coming out of print soon
October on the author of some open
source libraries including lifelines and
lifetimes and I'm a lead on the data
team at Shopify Shopify is headquarters
are in Ottawa ottawa canada ottawa
ontario canada this is a map of Canada
unlabeled I want you to think about
where is Ottawa on this on this map of
Canada just like make make a mental
guess I've been ready okay that's Ottawa
just kidding that's not Ottawa that's
Ottawa I think so let's get into um the
first mistake I made so this was a
competition me and I was I did this in
grad school with two of my my close
friends we were just getting to Python
the time Python at the time we you know
cycle learn was was just becoming like
really awesome
so we jumped into Python and
scikit-learn and started to attack this
problem the theme of the problem was we
needed to predict the census mail return
rate and that's defined as the number of
their like I would say this number of
census census mail outs that's the
denominator on top is a number of census
sheets returned to the Census Bureau
so the data looks like this it's at the
block level so think of block is like
the most granular data when you get when
you deal with census data think of it as
like a city block so it's sort of
aggregated at that level the data data
looks like this so there's the median
income for that block the margin of
error for that median income the
fraction Hispanic the margin of error
for that fresh fraction Hispanic
returned and sent so this is what the
raw data sort of looked like that's a
very simplified form so I'm predicting
the return rate so I just divided the
times returned by the total and I get
this rate cool that makes sense
I don't do any less margin of errors
doesn't really make it really make sense
if my margin of error increases why
should my return rate increase there's
no immediate idea there so I just knew
close and then I do data science so I
just import scikit-learn and just use
SVR which was you know pretty good
actually this was a simplified version
of what we did we had access to because
we were in grad school we had access to
University of Waterloo's big massive
supercomputer which was like awesome 200
gigs in like 64 nodes we were giddy
about this so we were like SSA Qing in
and in writing these massive like grid
searches and ensemble methods so this
was like simplification but we did some
pretty crazy things what was the outcome
that's the total failure we came in like
40 first place and like we never really
breached anything high at the time we
would had no idea what went wrong like
we were so confident three you know
bright young gentleman and we just like
threw up her hands we had no idea what
went wrong it wasn't until months later
so I read this great paper called the
most dangerous equation and if you get
anything out of this talk it's
definitely check out this paper it's
such a good read it's the maybe ten
years old now but just as relevant today
as it was was written and even like
fifty years ago so the author goes into
discussion about what is the most
dangerous equation and you might think
it's like Einstein's equations around
like nuclear warheads or some sort of
population growth model that might be
dangerous in fact the author suggests
that this is the most dangerous equation
and so in human readable words it's the
variance of the sample mean is equal to
the variance of the population divided
by the square divided by square root n
looks pretty innocent but actually can
can get abused so so easily the paper
has a great vignette about how it's
misused so there were some researchers
doing some some work in even if heard
this story I'd like to repeat it
researchers doing work in kidney cancer
rates per County in the US and they the
kidney cancer rates defined as the the
number of inhabitants or the number of
cases of kidney cancer divided by the
number of people in that County so they
looked at okay which counties have the
highest rate of incidence of kidney
cancer and they noticed it was mostly
like all the counties in the Midwest the
research was like yeah that makes sense
I mean lack of access to like good
hospitals high
tobacco use high alcohol use so okay
that makes sense and they looked at also
they also looked at the opposite so
which counties have the the best rates
or the lowest rate of kidney cancer and
they notice that oh yeah it's in the
Midwest that makes sense you know access
to clean water fresh air like hard work
ethic and so they came to opposite
conclusions based on the same data and
the problem was they weren't considering
the the sample size of those counties so
the paper that has this amazing picture
and if we were to plot the on the y-axis
the cancer incidence rate divided by on
the x axis it's the population size of
that county we see this classic
triangular distribution and this is this
is like a dagger in stats like if you
see this you have to be very very
careful so what's happening is in these
smaller counties we have low populations
maybe like a hundred people in this
county and if say zero of them have
cancer then your rate is zero if 50 of
them have cancer that's maybe a bad
estimate 10 of them have cancer this
kidney cancer then your rate is 10% so
with these small data sets or small
small counties you have high variation
in your estimate of the sample mean and
the sample mean in this case is the rate
so I saw this and I was so excited I
emailed my friend and friend I was like
I know why we messed up and so I did the
exact same thing for for our our data
and get the exact same shape so
some blocks have two or three people
living on them there was like a prison
was one with again like one inhabitant
in that prison so we see the classic
distribution and and that was the
problem with our with our data and we
didn't factor that in we just again if I
go back to what we did our
pre-processing I had this data
originally I transformed it naively to
this data and I shouldn't have done that
if you look at the like the sent it
varies in its population size and that's
gonna affect the margin of error in that
rate so that's where I messed up so 538
yesterday actually had a published
article about the best and worst board
games and the data data looks like this
so again classic distribution so the
y-axis is the average rating the x-axis
is the number of reviewers so like that
it's in this distribution this triangle
distribution is classic in in stats
actually it was funny when this was
posted a very predominant data scientist
commented on it and they actually fell
for the exact same error that I fell for
they said
I'm very interested in these two and he
circled the top two points now if I go
back here like those pop two points are
probably not the best games you know
what I mean like those are just by
chance they have some good ratings but
they're probably not the best games so
he this this individual fell for the
exact same problem that I did so what do
I learn I learned that sample sizes are
so so important when dealing with
aggregate level data we can't just
discard them or ignore them
interestingly point to their suggests
that if all the blocks are the exact
same sample sizes this wouldn't be an
issue the issue if that was true they
would all have the exact same variance
and I can do whatever I want but because
there's different sample sizes per block
that became an issue so what was needed
to do was like a weighted linear
regression or like a weighted something
something that takes into account the
sample sizes using the margin of error
don't ignore it I just discarded it but
the statisticians who gave me this
dataset they put it there for a reason I
shouldn't just ignore it that would been
very useful to have I think that was the
first thing I dropped was the margin of
error columns literally it was like is
mo e in column if so drop it was that
bad and then number four that I got
burned so bad here I
like became amazing because of it it was
it was so embarrassing I was like oh and
and then when you think about this this
problem from a Bayesian perspective it's
so obvious it's like oh yeah you have to
do that you have to consider the sample
size and what I was doing is I was using
like the I assumed the rate was like a
perfect estimate of that population
which was wrong so case study number two
I used to work in finance before I
started at Shopify and we should do some
trading some day trading so this this
graphic is intraday stocks for the SP
the Dow the Nasdaq in the foot see the
foot sees like the UK index that's the
one in yellow the markets open
differently at different times so
suppose you are interested in doing some
day trading your target is UK stocks in
particular the futures on the foot see
so you go to Bloomberg or Yahoo Finance
and you pull some data and your datum
set might look like this we have time
series the footsie here at the footsie
the Dow Jones and the VIX the VIX is
just like another stock your postback
testing results look great and back
testing is the financial version of
cross-validation how it works is you
train on this portion of data you
predict on the next and then you move
ahead one so you train on this portion
of data drift on the next and keep doing
that it's like cross validation but sort
of deterministic so the you know these
these look great you're making money
you're piell's through the roof and then
you push it to production and investing
real money and it sinks luckily this
didn't happen to me it got caught like I
noticed this mistake before I went to
production so when actually lose any
money but it was it was an obvious
problem at the time so what but wrong
data leakage happened and this is
something I never thought about before
except in like production data so what
is data leakage in this data leakage in
this context so if we go back to this
graph let's say I was always predicting
end of day prices for the foot see this
yellow line using end of day prices for
the other three lines now the problem
was the foot see or the other three
lines the red blue and orange they
contained information about the end of
day price for the foot see so
how does that work so it was if why is
the foot see that it's the independent
or the target variable is y which is the
foot see that was influencing X these
other three variables which I was trying
to know I was trying to use X to predict
Y so there was data leakage there I
wasn't really considering the footsies
sort of like relationship to the other
stocks does that make sense
while it occurred I'm seeing some heads
yeah okay cool so what did I learn this
is an important one so you're back
testing slash cross-validation will
always be equal to or overly optimistic
and it's a plan for that
you'll never get you know that 90%
classification rate you do in your back
or your cross-validation simulations and
number two is understand where your
source data comes from understand it
from like right from beginning right to
the end so this was a case where I just
naively used our data warehouse to pull
and update prices I'm not ignoring sort
of time zones and issues like that but I
should have looked at like okay where's
this data coming from what's that ETL
process I understand that part the third
mistake that I made was a testing
mistake so we saw two great talks
yesterday about how to do testing by
Trey and Chris and this is this wasn't a
mistake that I made early on so life
Lyons is a survival analysis or viable
analysis package that I work on and one
of the most important pieces in survival
analysis is the log-rank test it's like
the hypothesis test for a survival
analysis I got an email one day from an
individual using lifelines any very sort
of sheepishly very like beat around the
bush the issue that you know I compared
this versus our and and I looked at your
package I think there's an error and I
talking a little bit deeper and it was
true there was actually an error inside
my implementation it would there weren't
like P that the P values weren't far off
but they were off enough so I had to
wrote like fix the bug immediately roll
a new release and release it so the
problems didn't have enough tests for
that implementation so what I learned
was when developing city school city
school software that already exists in
the wild it's best to test against that
software what
should have done is right my
implementation I get a bunch of like
input values and they compare that
output versus ours output and actually
hard code that our output into my test
just to confirm and never make sure
never do regression and secondly just be
responsible for for software I have to
go like go out to like people's repos
who are using lifelines and like post a
message saying you know please upgrade
to 0.7 yeah so that's that's the the dis
value in open source software there
might be these bugs the fourth mistake
that I made was an a/b testing mistake
so this was right around the time I
joined Shopify and this was my first a B
test I was super excited I was like
probate I was like yeah we'll do this
Bayesian it's all gonna be good so got
the data did the analysis the beta test
told me that yes these are significantly
different control group at four percent
conversion rate experiment coop at five
percent I'm making these numbers up but
that's what it looked like so upper
management wanted to know okay what was
the relative increase what was like the
lift on that experiment so I just you
know five percent minus four percent
divided by four percent 25 percent lift
so but then the Gmail ship it send it to
the execs no I again I forgot sample
size and that that's it's so so
important that sample size number so
what happened and you actually you might
have seen like headlines like this and
he's always make me laugh how a single
a/b test increased conversion by three
hundred and thirty six percent or two
hundred eleven eleven percent and below
that it's like a hundred and forty
percent I saw one that was a thousand
percent increase and the gentleman in
the article called it a unicorn
experiment and that just made me laugh
so what's what's causing these like
enormous lifts like what's going on here
are these people just like getting the
decimals wrong or something so let's go
back to that that Bayesian a/b tests so
if you're unfamiliar with babies I'll
give you a quick like instruction what
I'm displaying here these are two
posterior curves of the conversion rate
for Group A and Group B so this red
curve it's the distribution of what I
think the conversion rate for group a
might look like so it's probably the
conversion rates probably between like
0.3 can you see my yeah sweet is between
like 0.3
and 0.5 probably around like 0.39 0.039
excuse me that's the conversion rate for
group a for group B it's probably
between 0.4 and 0.6 so somewhere around
there so that's great that that makes
sense in my mind my inference was
correct like these word distinct
conversion rates likely so what I should
have done next and what I didn't do or
should have done next is start sampling
from these distributions so a sample
from the red distribution a sample from
the blue distribution and then compute
the relative increase so sampled from
one I get P of a stammerer from two we
get P of B so I've P of a minus P V P B
divided by P of B that's like the lift I
know I can do that thousands of times
because it's cheap and if I did that
what is the distribution of those
relative increases look like and it
looks like this so this is a very
different distribution it's very notice
how wide it is it goes from like it
below zero to about you know up to eight
really so this is the distribution of
possible relative increases from my very
simple experiment so this is why you see
these massive numbers like three hundred
percent and a thousand percent it's
because there's so much variance and
what that relative increase could be
that yeah you might get a thousand
percent doesn't mean it is a thousand
percent but it means there's on that
draw you got a thousand percent and this
goes back to problem I like to talk
about I often talk about it I like to
talk about it's the problem between or
the the the dilemma between the binary
problem in a/b testing and the
continuous problem in a/b testing so the
binary problem is which group is better
that's a binary problem it's either
Group A or Group B it's yes or no it's 0
or 1 the sample space is only like 0 or
1 so it's very it's trivial to solve
that problem you just need to collect
data and do the a/b test and you get the
result that's what the a/b tests or even
like any hypothesis testing was designed
for the binary problem the dilemma comes
in when you try to solve the continuous
problem and the continuous problem is
how much better and that's a very very
different question if you think about
the range of values that problem could
take on or this is the solution could
take on it could be from negative
infinity all the way to infinity so we
really you need orders of magnitude more
data
to solve that continuous problem but yet
that's really what people want people
want to know how much more they want to
solve the continuous problem using the
binary problem or the binary problem
solution but the a/b test isn't designed
for the continuous problem so that's why
you get these ridiculous numbers that
look just crazy okay so what do you do
you can't just like give your executive
this distribution that's very rude and
they don't know what to do with it
so what you want to do is you want to
pick a summary stat from this
distribution so I've labeled some points
here
there's the mean is that one of the most
left yeah left my left and but that's
the the distribution sort of skewed so
you don't really want to pick the mean
because that skewness is gonna like push
it too much to the right or left yeah
whatever or you can you can pick the a
better option as a 50th percentile of
that distribution that's pretty robust
like it's not going to be affected by
that skewness I tend to find that that
is still a little bit too too overly
optimistic I like to pick the 30th
percentile there's are many reasons for
choosing that one that I like is that
it's it underestimates the the true
value so being very conservative and
when I tell my boss that means there
they don't get all like crazy with like
huge numbers they sort of like form a
sort of calm about the number it also
with some nice properties that it's
efficient in the sense that if I keep
acquiring more data
eventually the mean the median and the
30th percentile will all converge the
same number so like I'm not being
incorrect so I like to choose the 30th
percentile for for these numbers so what
I learned I learned don't naively
compute stats on top of stats that just
compounds uncertainty it like in in in
nonlinear ways you can't really measure
that very reliably it's better to
underestimate than overestimate so
that's using that 30 percent versus like
50 percent example so better to be like
home the better to err on the side of
conservative and this is just more
generally I think visualizing
uncertainty is the role of the
statistician if you think of any stats
problem it is applies to data science as
well if you think of any stats problem
hypothesis testing or like a linear
regression
like that what this opposition is doing
is actually taking all the uncertainty
that they have and putting it in certain
spots so they might like stick it in one
particular area and make it like very
tight and one sort of like point or they
might put over here make it very flat or
they might like make it bimodal for the
role that statistician is to like take
that uncertainty and put it somewhere
they can't just like sweep it under the
rug and give you like a single value
they have to like put it somewhere and
it's always present it might be very
sharp at one point but it's always
present and that's what I did in this
exercise and visualize the uncertainty
and I saw how wrong I could have been
and then I based on that I Drive better
estimates of what to do from there
excuse me a second so the I've two more
examples one second
I have two more examples these are a bit
more mathy so I'm able go a little bit
slower
the first one is sparse applying the
solution naively I should a choice or
change the title or whatever so let's
say I do a regression a linear
regression and I get these beta values
so I have ten it easily the the
estimated coefficient so I have ten ten
and zero point one assume the data has
been normalized as well so there's no
like well this is a different order this
variables a different order of magnitude
than this one assume it's all like zero
one or like it's mean 0 standard
deviation is one so there's no ways you
there okay so it might be good idea to
like drop that lost variable if you go
back to this like it's not contributing
a whole lot to that regression if X 3
the third variable changes a lot like
it's all really gonna affect you know
the response variable very much also say
say that that feature is very hard to
generate it requires like new data
pipelines and like it's computationally
intense so might be if you drop that
variable then you don't have to like
create those pipelines and do that
future engineering which is good that's
good
so that might not be a bad idea
everything is okay maybe well suppose
this is the true model so X 1 is some X
1 is equal to like normal 0 1 it's not
noise like normal 0 1 just generating
fake data it's not like don't think of
it
no it's just fake data x2 is equal to
this weird 0.001 normal 0 1 minus x1
I'll get to that x3 is again normal 0 1
and then Y is generated by 10 times x1
plus 10 times x2 plus 0.1 times x3 so we
did get the right coefficients if you go
back to that linear regression output we
got the right coefficients 10 10 0 1 0
point 1 so we got that right
but let's go a little bit deeper let's
do some algebra so if I had 10 times x1
plus 10 times x2 if you just do the
algebra what I get is 0.1 0.01 times
some data some normal data so actually
together x1 and x2 contribute very
little to why in fact an order of
magnitude less than what x3 contributes
if you recall the koifish on the next
three is 0.1 if I combine X 2 and X 1 I
get 0.01 that's an order of magnitude
less so in fact these together aren't
consuming a whole lot to Y so if I were
to drop that x3 variable I've like lost
most of my information about why does
that make sense it's yeah I should have
like an eye Python network that does
that but ok so what's the solution here
what was better what should I have done
basically any form of regularization
will solve this it'll correctly the
problem was that x1 and x2 were highly
highly correlated if I go back to that
definition you can see like they're
super correlated it's a linear
regression is not like it's a dumb it's
dumb method it's not gonna pick up on
that on that correlation any sum of any
form of Ridge Ridge regression or like
l1 l2 regressions or penalization that
will solve this so if I did that I get
this if I did even a slightest bit of
positive l2 regression I get this so it
looks a lot better you can see that its
significance it's shrunk basically the
coefficients of x1 and x2 close to 0 and
it's maintained like a decent positive
value for X 3 so it's maybe like a bad
example because like whoever does a
straight linear regression anymore but
it's just like it's a machine learning
counter example that's supposed to be
esoteric and fun so everything's good
and my last example is
PC a before regression and this is
something that you know sounds
reasonable and you might see it in like
texts and and tutorials online and even
textbooks or what your professor might
teach so PC is great at many things but
it can significantly hurt
regression as if it's used as a
pre-processing pre-processing step how
does that occur
so supposed to wish to regress Y onto X
and W suppose the true model of Y is X
minus W but we don't know this that's
hidden from us nature created that we
want to infer that furthermore suppose
that there is a positive correlation
between X and W say 0.5 so I apply PCA
to the matrix XW and I get this new
matrix I'm not going to read it but
that's what I get
that's just like PCA that's what's gonna
do here and I've repeated on the next
slide so that that's the new matrix on
the top so any textbook any textbook on
my seat Michigan learning your professor
might suggest this or a friend might
suggest this like it's good to look at
the explained variance ratios so if I
did that here I would see that the first
column has most of the explained
variance about 80% of the explained
variance the second column has very
little so the recommendation from a
textbook or professor will be just drop
that second variable it doesn't there's
no information in it you don't really
need it okay so you do that and now we
are regressing Y on to this new column
vector which is 1 over root 2 X plus 1
over root 2 W so now I want to find
values alpha beta such that y equals
alpha plus beta X plus W is a good fit
but there are no good values for that
recall that Y is equal to X minus W so
you can't find a good alpha and beta
that really like solve that so this is
actually a pretty good example so here I
have just like it I Pratt the notebook
so I have Rho is equal to 0.5 that's my
correlation coefficient I generate a
thousand data points so W is defined
this is like how you create correlated
correlated variables and so y is equal
to
- w cool and you can see that yeah it's
about 0.5 correlation between x and y or
x + w so i do this i port cycle or
import pca from scikit-learn I've n
components equals 1 which means that I
only keep one vector the first vector or
the one with the highest explained
variance ratio so I have to create this
new matrix called X bar which is just a
fit transform of the matrix X W which is
exactly what I had in my slides I roll
that and then I import linear regression
basically do the lro fit X bar Y stuff
and what do I get
so this last number is the r-squared
value so it's a measly 0.006 oh of
course yeah sweet so that's that's
pretty terrible what like what happened
if I actually went back and did the
exact same thing but didn't do PCA
beforehand I get an r-squared value of 1
which makes sense and that's what that's
what I should get because Y is fully
determined by X and W oh yeah quickly
about the demo we did that so what I
learned or the solution to this just
don't use naive PCA before regression
you're losing information better to use
there's something called supervised PCA
or just don't do PCA before regression
that's another good strategy those are
my six mistakes that I made in my in my
time as a statistician slash data
scientist thanks for listening any
questions
cool if you have questions I'll be
around yeah sure yeah I'll tweet the
slides and that's the best way to do it
sure yeah big do you want me out of the
field is that what you're suggesting
kind of yeah well not not give up but I
think we should start to like share
these ideas and like this is where I
messed up and this was the solution I
guess like an interviews like and
programming interviews they often asked
like what's the hardest problem you've
debugged maybe an equivalent for like
stats and data science might be like
what's the hardest or what's like the
most calm or like counterintuitive
result you've seen something like that
might be good question but no not give
up yeah not really we have yeah it is
it's just like it's small little stories
and vignettes about like right right
yeah right
do you really have to have a PhD in
statistics or give you ideally no things
like blog articles would be a good
solution but like these need to be
uncovered or like those electrical
engineers that would not throw it data
if they saw the analogy and what machine
learners were doing or like at least
like beginner machine learners we're
doing with like PCA before linear
regression
so like stopping them or even like
putting a stop to the toriel's that
suggests that before yeah but I don't
think there's any books like that there
was an amazing book this is whatever I
came from an amazing book called like
counter examples and probability theory
everybody said counter examples and
stats and that's whatever idea of like
the idea for like counter examples of
machine learning came from so something
like that would be cool for like applied
stats I think that's like pretty
theoretical book I was talking about oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah cool yeah that
sounds really good
I would say yeah for sure a lot of like
small companies haven't hired like a
full-time like experienced fielded
statistician or data scientist so it's
like what does that financial example I
was the only like statistician at that
work and I was like new out of college
or you know at new university so that
was a pretty easy mistake for me to make
but someone who had experience we like
no you can't do that so yeah I would but
I mean the field is really young and
companies are young and they don't want
to hire like a full-time you know
various individual Saiga it wasn't
unicorns yeah so to answer question like
yes that would be a good idea yeah I
thought about the idea of everyone hates
like the first year or second year like
stats courses and university those are
pretty bad it'd be great to like
reversals on their head and like let's
do a quote or course on simulation first
and then we can do the stats class
afterwards once you like you're familiar
with like distributions and and I'd like
to simulate these things so that'd be
like a nicer approach to two stats to
start from the simulation and then go
into inference yeah in the back
basically stats debugging yeah right a
few of these work from there so like I
post on there pretty often and I posted
a few of these problems and if you know
Wu burr on that website he's amazing
yeah I think he corrected me a few times
I mean that's his blog platform yeah
he's really good yeah
yeah but I had to go back and forth I
wear the hat different hats many times
yeah so the he's suggesting the Jains is
a theory of probability or right yeah
yeah yeah yeah cool
okay well thank you very much I hope you
guys enjoyed pike on the PI data